I really no no no you do not trim these
hedges from top to bottom but from
bottom to top as we've discussed many
times I might now trim the bushes myself
then you can cut the grass you cut the
grass yesterday yes what can I do for
you miss Waller I request a formal
introduction are you firing me you
should be so lucky
fishermen the thought of leaving my
obituary to chance is completely
unreasonable to me well I am the
obituary writer so when the time comes I
will be writing her obituary I want you
to write it now huh here's the names of
a few hundred people my name is Anne
Sherman I'm from the first look is that
I'd like to talk to you about Harriette
Lawler now the deceased should be loved
by their family there's an ex-husband
he's a jackass sorry lemon bream go from
the looks of it I'm not sure you do the
deceased must have touched someone's
life I hated her so much if I want your
opinion I will give it to you that's
what she told me I was her gynecologist
there's just one thing you could say
about her that's nice if she were dead
that would be nice
how's that
Wow she put the [ __ ] in obituary how
grossly I overestimated your talent as a
writer the problem isn't with my writing
that was just me writing about your life
my life is not over yet we're gonna help
shape a legacy this is we've defined it
youth to mold and that will be the
person whose life I touch you got busted
for drunk driving
did we excuse me your light and your
hair when I was a kid I loved to write
I'd like a job as a disc jockey and what
kind of music would you play the right
question would be what would I play
after I played the kinks and who is this
it's my intern
why not I just lose my job to a 100 year
old woman
this is her lip Lawler saying please
don't have a nice day I don't know if I
can write your obituary was not ready to
close this chapter of my life have a day
that matters have a day that's true
every day that means something
your piece of work I am Who I am
[Music]
you
[Music]
you